c'est non non on ne va pas attendre plus
longtemps
on va demander aux professeurs pierre
desproges ce qu'il pense du sportif
oui en fait j'ai et dresser un portrait
psychosomatiques du sportif commun alors
tout d'abord on peut dire qu'on divise
les sportifs en trois grandes catégories
les mâles les femelles et les nageuses
est-allemande
alors pour en venir directement au mode
de vie du sportif commun comme l'homme
le sportif est un mammifère il se
reproduit donc comme l'homme quand le
sportif sans monter en lui l'appel
irrésistible du désir c'est plus fort
que lui il faut qu'il aille au stade
alors il va au stade et ça passe moins
imaginative la femme du sportif sentant
grandir en elle l'appelle du désir va
aux coiffeurs et non pas chez le
coiffeur où ils risqueraient de
rencontrer la coiffeuse de sucre en
dénombre en france cinq grandes espèces
de sportif le cycliste d'abord qui est
très importante
le cycliste moyen est viscéralement sous
doués
d'ailleurs il a la tête plus bas que le
cul surtout dans les côtes on peut
l'observer assez facilement au lit comme
à bicyclette la caractéristique du
cycliste et qu'il espère faire mieux la
prochaine fois
le cycliste à une seconde peau qui
s'appelle le maillot jaune c'est un
simple maillot de type jean-edern
hallier c'est à dire que on le voit très
bien l'image même de très loin et qui
s'enlève tout seul le tennis aussi
d'autre part le tennis est un sport
noble mais ennuyeux comme on a pu en
juger
récemment en écoutant le commentaire
radiophonique de la finale de roland
garros
ces villas skipass haviland air qui
passe à villa ce qui passe là c'est un
peu chiant la boxe maintenant monsieur
limite au plateau on a beaucoup mais 10
de la boxe on a même prétendu que les
anciens boxeurs à la retraite devenaient
de véritables épaves humaine
c'est complètement faux il existe des
anciens boxeurs heureux il lisse
tranquillement pif le chien en braille
et tout va mieux pour eux alphonse
halimi réaliser les courses je ne
retiens que tout allait bien gentil pour
changer à mon époque pour changer venons
en aux courses qui sont le sport le plus
distingué en france les hippodromes
d'ailleurs son plein de mégots mais de
vieilles baronne en perd loose et qui
regardent des nains bariolés filets des
coupes de pompe dans le bide à des
canassons en sûr qu'ils auront rien fait
c'est baronne achètent leurs
avec l'argent des allocations familiales
que les besogneux vienne claqué aux
courses c'est le sport national français
le football maintenant bien que
l'essentiel de son savoir-faire se situe
au niveau de ses pieds le footballeur
est également fort bien musclé du haut
on cite notamment le cas du footballeur
platini dans le tour de poitrine atteint
118 cm 110 cm entre le thème est le
deuxième haut de marlborough et un drôle
de regard des sportifs la haute cour un
ouais ouais
pour finir il ya une question que l'on
peut se poser y at il une intelligence
du sportif oui elle est sensiblement
d'ailleurs la même chez le footballeur
le tennisman le jockey le cheval ou le
boxeur le quotient intellectuel du
sportif moyens et voisin de celui de
l'autruche d'ailleurs si l'autriche
baisse la tête c'est pas du tout pour se
l'offrir dans le sable c'est pour avoir
l'air d'un coureur c'est bien connu pour
finir un chiffre le record mondial du
plus bas quotient intellectuel chez un
sportif est détenu actuellement par le
soviétique youri corsi kof
c'est lui qui a tenté en vain d'ailleurs
d'imposer aux derniers jeux olympiques
le lancement du poing sur glace c'est au
nom
[Musique]